The year is 1985.
16th of February.
A pair of researchers aboard a Model SM-03
deep sea submersible are descending into the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean.
Hours ago, they were somewhere just off the
coast of France, surrounded by blue sky, the
smell of the sea, and the warm embrace of
the sun.
But now, only cold darkness surrounds them.
The depth of the ocean so vast and overwhelming
even light could not escape it’s grasp.
The two-man team are members of MTF Gamma-6,
also known as the DEEP FEEDERS a special task
force that specializes in the investigation
and tracking of deep-sea or oceanic anomalies.
Their mission; to locate and investigate the
wreckage of a WW2 German warship known as
the Bismarck, thought by the general public
to have gone down in a naval battle with the
British in 1941.
But the story the public doesn’t know..
is the real reason the pair of Foundation
members were tasked with locating the ship’s
wreckage site.
Unfortunately for these researchers, today
would be remembered for something far worse
than they had anticipated.
Radio transmissions recorded by the Gamma-6
duo, detailed the events that took place upon
finding the The Bismarck designated SCP-4217.
The Bismarck lay at the bottom of the ocean
partially submerged in the sea floor, but,
to the astonishment of researchers, it appeared
to be perfectly intact, with no signs of damage
from it’s previous naval engagements.
Gamma-6 member Charles Miller comments:
“Even after the better part of five decades,
this ship is still in pristine condition.
There is no water damage anywhere that I can
see.
Even stranger, no ocean sediment has accumulated
on the hull of the ship whatsoever.”
Prompted to investigate closer, agent Victor
Miller begins operation of the crew’s Model
RV-1 Marine Probe, an unmanned robotic exploratory
drone that allows the researchers to explore
the interior of the ship’s wreckage.
What they found unnerved them.
Or better said, what they didn't find.
Just as the outside of the vessel appeared
free of any corrosion or wear, the interior
of the ship was just as immaculate.
The hallways were clean, the walls adorned
freshly printed signs in still legible German.
Even the Nazi symbols painted onto command
centers still held no sign of disintegration.
It was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line.
But strangest of all was the lack of skeletal
remains.
At the time it was sunk, the original crew
of the Bismarck boasted a minimum of two thousand
men.
Where were their bodies?
Continuing the mission, the researchers piloted
their unmanned drone down the eerie winding
corridors.
Along several of the inner corridors of the
submerged wreckage of SCP-4217, the crew find
large thick walls of what appear to be made
out of a rubber-like substance.
Soon they find that the large vein-like growths
extend throughout the interior of the ship
like tendrils, growing in size the closer
the exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel.
All the while a slight hum sound is picked
up by the craft’s sonar equipment, echoing
from the center of the ship, a rhythmic pulsing.
The crew decide they need to take a sample
of the rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing.
This would be a mistake.
Upon cutting into the thick tentacle-like
growths, the researchers notice something
that fills their stomachs with dread.
Whatever substance they had cut into was now
bleeding.
The team hears a distant rumble growing steadily
louder.
Suddenly the ship begins to move!
Shuffling sand and debris strew along the
seafloor, clouding the visibility of the ship.
Terrified - the pair hurry to try and disconnect
the cable attaching the probe to their submersible
and evacuate the site.
But it’s too late.
A booming thud shakes the underwater craft
as a large shadow covers the glass window
of the submersible.
Alarm systems go off as cracks start to appear
in the glass surface.
The pair attempt to pilot the vessel up toward
the surface but they are halted by a strong
force pulling them downward.
Just as the cracks start to spread across
the surface of the glass, a giant shadow looms
over the submersible.
“Wha-..what is that?!”
Screams and the sound of shattering glass
can be heard on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery depths.
Since that unfortunate event, Foundation members
have recorded multiple occurances of SCP-4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the Atlantic,
particularly off the coast of the United Kingdom
and as far north as the Greenland Sea.
Given it’s Keter containment classification,
containment of SCP-4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation naval forces with
the cooperation of the British Royal Navy.
In episodes of aggression or an “agitated
or hostile state”, naval forces are instructed
to forcibly subdue SCP-4217 through naval
engagement.
Once enough damage is sustained, SCP-4217
enters a “passive” state and re-submerges.
SCP-4217 is divided into two parts.
SCP-4217-A is the Bismarck itself - a Nazi-era
warship outfitted with an array of 8 main
guns, 44 secondary armaments, and a dozen
units of anti-aircraft weaponry.
SCP-4217-B refers to the “anomalous cephalopod
organism” embedded inside the hull of the
ship.
SCP-4217-B has two large rectangular pupils
inside of octopoid eyes that protrude from
the base of the ship, as well as twelve 100
to 200 meter-long tendril-like muscular appendages
that extend outward from an opening in the
stern of the vessel.
SCP-4217 is deemed to be classification risk
class: Dangerous, with reports of it emitting
a mild psionic field within a 20 km radius,
confusing anything within range and increasing
the likelihood of friendly fire among enemy
combatants.
SCP-4217-A’s hull seems to have the ability
of inorganic regeneration, as damage incurred
from enemy vessels seem to immaculately repair
over time.
Researchers have observed what appear to be
runes or cryptic markings on the sides of
SCP-4217-A’s hull.
It is believed these symbols were part of
the original ship’s design to bolster the
vessel’s defensive integrity.
Though not immediately visible, when the vessel
is taking fire, the symbols appear to glow
“in proportion to the amount of damage being
mitigated”.
Among it’s offensive capabilities, apart
from the standard armaments of a WW2 era warship,
SCP-4217-A also has specialized munitions
of an unidentifiable gas compound that is
reported to have “mutagenic properties”.
Individuals that have been exposed to the
gas compound undergo rapid spontaneous metamorphosis
at a molecular level, growing an array of
evolutionary attributes which include the
accumulation of reptile-like scales or avian
feathers in place of skin, the increase or
decrease of the number of limbs, digits, or
even ocular, olfactory, or auditory, organs,
and in one reported case, an event where multiple
members of one crew were fused at a subatomic
level into one functioning organism, though
more study into this particular incident is
needed.
SCP-4217 also has the ability of sub-surface
oceanic mobility, and can submerge itself
when not in combat with enemy vessels.
Underwater propulsion appears to be generated
by ejection of water from SCP-4217-B’s body
cavity, and reaches a top speed of approximately
30 knots.
SCP-4217 undergoes cycles of passive behavior
that is periodically interrupted by moments
of hostility towards civilian craft, particularly
resurfacing and going after trans-atlantic
cargo vessels.
It is believed this is analogous to the history
and original mission of the Bismarck, operation
Rheinubung.
During World War 2, the German Luftwaffe were
besieging London in a series of nightly air
raids that would be colloquially known as
the Blitz.
It was the grand intention of the Third Reich
to cut off supplies to the British to limit
their resistance to the Nazi war machine.
However what pestered the Nazis most and hindered
this effort was the consistant American support
provided by the U.S. government in the form
of food and supplies delivered to the British
via Atlantic trade routes by cargo ship.
The German Bismarck and her sister ship, the
Tirpitz, were created for the very goal of
stopping these transports of cargo to the
United Kingdom, as well as sinking as many
allied vessels as possible.
The year is 1937.
In a top secret effort to make preparations
for an approaching war, Adolf Hitler turns
to his most trusted expert on the supernatural,
chief SS officer Heinrich Himmler.
Among other projects, Himmler ordered the
Ahnenerbe Obskurakorps, a German organization
tasked with the procurement and investigation
of otherworldly or otherwise unexplainable
phenomenon, to begin the creation of two ships,
the Bismarck and the Tirpitz, the former named
after the Iron Chancellor, Otto Von Bismarck,
who in 1890 unified the German people.
These vessels were to be created using recently
uncovered technological oddities the Obskurakorps
had found in their studies of the occult.
Sources of information about the exact creation
of SCP-4217 are highly expunged from the record.
But bits and pieces did survive among what
little the Foundation was able to collect
and in the records of the USSR after their
occupation of Eastern Germany following the
fall of the Nazi regime during the second
world war.
The earliest mention of SCP-4217’s conception
dates back to early 1937, when a top-secret
shipment of unknown materials labeled as “components
of thaumatological constructs” is intercepted
by a Foundation agent working undercover in
a German shipment center outside of Hamburg.
The Foundation agent, Markus Straub, is instructed
to maintain surveillance on the shipment.
In 1939, upon near completion of the soon
to be chirstianed “Bismarck”, a second
shipment labeled with the insignia of the
Obskuracorps is intercepted by the Foundation
agent.
Only this shipment appears unlike any other.
Reports of the massive shipping container
holding machinery capable of aquatic life
support indicate organic living cargo.
Though the Foundation agent was unable to
identify the exact nature of the contents
of the shipment, Straub reported hearing sounds
emanating from the cargo hold.
Sounds similar to that of a heartbeat.
Just a year later the Bismarck is seen making
its first naval trial run when it experiences
a massive electrical discharge just offshore,
shutting the vessel down momentarily until
power was restored shortly after.
Reports show luminescent symbols briefly visible
on the hull of the ship.
Thaumatological symbols, for the layman, are
symbols that embody the “study of miracles”.
Because of this, it was apparent to the Foundation
that some occult anomaly was responsible for
the strange characteristics of the German
vessel, and an order for termination was reached
by the O5 council.
The hunt for SCP-4217:
In the autumn of 1940, under orders of neutralization
of SCP-4217, all active Foundation agents
presiding in Germany were ordered to converge
on the site of the Bismark to stop the completion
of the vessel.
But when the time came for the operation,
every single one of the Foundation agents
vanished.
No records of what happened were ever found,
no clothing, notes, not even a trace of their
existence was left behind.
The mission was deemed a failure, and subsequent
attempts to neutralize SCP-4217 became far
more difficult after the Bismarck received
a full crew of seamen.
The fully manned and well equipped SCP-4217
became a menace to both military and civilian
craft on the high seas of the Atlantic, at
times appearing without warning seemingly
out of thin air.
SCP-4217’s psionic field obscured it from
the new technological advancements in enemy
radar systems the U.S. government had in development.
The ship became a shadow on the Atlantic,
a subject of ghost stories for anyone daring
to assist the British government with the
war effort.
Furthermore, SCP-4217 did not seem to be content
with the surrender of enemy vessels.
Captured enemy ships were gassed, turning
the men into manufactured beasts, and then
sinking the enemy vessels to the depths of
the Ocean.
Even submarines were no match, on one report
describing an attempt to elude the vessel
by diving below the surface, only to be entangled
by enormous squid-like appendages that dragged
the craft back up to the surface before crushing
it in its grasp.
Fearing for the safety of the public, the
O5 council decided they could not stand by
and let more innocent lives be taken.
They voted to supersede the Foundation’s
policy on absolute secrecy to notify the British
government of the danger SCP-4217 posed to
maritime civilians.
With cooperation from the British Royal Navy,
Foundation representatives joined the crew
of HMS Hood and HMS Prince of Wales to track
reports of the Bismarck being sighted off
the coast of Scandinavia.
In what history books would come to know as
the battle of the Denmark Strait, HMS Hood
and HMS Prince of Wales engage SCP-4217 and
a secondary German warship known as the Prinz
Eugen.
Confused by the ship’s psionic field, the
British naval ships experience trouble identifying
the Bismarck and engage in friendly fire before
being able to regain control of their armaments,
concentrating all volley of fire on SCP-4217.
The attack proves futile, as after the embers
and smoke of munitions fire wear off, the
sides of the Bismarck’s hull appear to vibrate
with glowing energy.
Mangled metal begins to straighten back into
perfect frame, breaches in armor begin to
heal before the soldier’s very eyes, and
all that is left as evidence the ship had
ever taken fire is a cloud of steam emanating
from the hull of SCP-4217.
The waters surrounding the vessel begin to
boil as underwater tentacles lurch out and
capture the HMS Hood, dragging her majesty’s
ship forward.
The men aboard frantically try to regain control,
but seconds later are met with another crisis.
A salvo of artillery shells fired from SCP-4217’s
guns hits the ship, severing lines and damaging
rail guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen.
In mere minutes, the majority of the crew
are engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsions, their bodies undergoing
rapid involuntary mutagenesis including the
growth of limbs, the development of fur, feathers
and scales.
In one report, it was said that multiple victims
even fused together to create one single horrifying
entity.
Those exposed to the gaseous compound were
designated SCP-4217-1.
The captain of the HMS Hood barricades himself
inside the helm, but the resulting instances
of SCP-4217-1 overpower the ship and neutralize
command.
In the seconds that follow, any witness of
the horror that the men aboard the HMS Hood
experienced is forever entombed in the watery
grave of the British vessel, as the ship is
sunk by a volley of munitions fire from the
combined might of the German fleet.
Some men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their legs
by the mutated instances of SCP-4217 and pulled
under, lungs filling with sea water as they
scream until their breath is no more.
In disbelief, the crew of HMS Prince of Wales
decides to retreat.
In the days that followed, at the bequest
of Foundation members, the British Royal Navy
launches a full scale armada to hunt down
and neutralize the Bismarck.
Though SCP-4217 sustained little damage in
the previous encounter, the ship began leaking
a black oil-like substance thought by SCP
researchers to be an organic waste product
of SCP-4217-B.
The allied naval force are able to follow
the trail to the coast of France, where, under
the lead of HMS King George V, British warships
surround the German vessel and open fire.
This time they were ready.
With approval from the O5 Council, Foundation
members provide the British forces with enhanced
munitions and armament capable of overwhelming
SCP-4217’s thaumatological defenses.
On the eve of battle, it appears to the allied
force that the psionic field generated by
SCP-4217 is too great, as the naval company
find it difficult to land targeted assaults
on the German vessel.
After losing several smaller vessels to the
colossal appendages of SCP-4217, Foundation
members on board authorize the use of a redacted
SCP.
It is brought in to deactivate SCP-4217’s
psionic field.
The tide of battle turns.
And after a fierce battle, SCP-4217 becomes
imobile and unable to return fire.
Relentless, the British continue their bombardment
until the artillery munitions on the ship
explode into a giant fireball, flooding the
ship’s compartments with the noxious fumes
of the mutagenic compound.
It’s crew members either jump overboard
or are engulfed in the cloud of gas.
The British vessels capture any survivors
and watch as SCP-4217 slowly sinks below the
waves, down to the depths of the ocean where
it would lay dormant for the next 48 years.
SCP-4217’s 121 surviving crew members were
captured and interrogated.
Most of the low-ranking German soldiers were
released to British custody, 109 of them having
their memory wiped by Foundation staff.
12 remaining members of the crew were sent
to Site-23 for further detention and advanced
interrogation, and 74 of the instances of
SCP-4217-1, the mutated subjects, were recovered
and sent to Site-23 for further observation.
It was thought that on that day SCP-4217 was
deemed neutralized and no longer a matter
of priority.
The Bismarck sunk into memory and myth.
It was only until the recent resurgence of
SCP-4217 that the Foundation saw the need
to collect as much information on the organism
inhabiting SCP-4217-A as possible.
Decades-old manuscripts and ledgers were pulled
from hundreds of viable sources.
From the intelligence then gathered, Foundation
members have come to the hypothesis that the
entity powering the vessel known as the Bismarck
has what is believed to be extra-planetary
origin.
World War 2 era documents uncovered between
Commander Karl Reuter, of the German Obskuracorps,
and a Dr. Hans Meyer, indicate a discovery
of an organic life form of unknown origin
found in a crashed aircraft near Feldberg
Peak in the Black Forest Mountain Range in
Germany.
Further correspondence with Obskuracorps members
Otto Schmidt and Dietrich Klossner indicate
that researchers were conducting trials on
the creature’s ability to create pisonic
fields, and to control or confuse enemy subjects
within it’s range, with a letter from Dietrich
Klossner suggesting the creature could be
used as a power source for an unspecified
“engine”.
Further evidence of SCP-4217-B’s extra-planetary
origin can be found in a 1993 incident between
Foundation naval ship SCPS Nemed and SCP-4217.
This is the only incident on record where
contact was established with the creature
classified as SCP-4217-B.
On July 22nd, SCP-4217 had reappeared off
the coast of Britain.
Anticipating hostility, SCPS Nemed, SCPS Cesair,
and SCPS Parthalon were instructed to close
in on SCP-4217’s location with orders to
subdue the vessel if necessary.
However, on this occasion, SCP-4217 did not
appear to be after any vessel.
It was simply drifting along at sea, no propulsion
engines active.
Noticing the change in SCP-4217’s behavior,
captain Kurt Wegner decided to withhold military
engagement and investigate SCP-4217’s behavior.
Sailing within 200 meters of the Bismarck,
the SCPS Nemed attempted radio contact with
the German vessel.
After repeated attempts at communication,
the crew were met with only silence and static
chatter.
Giving up, Captain Wegner puts down the radio
receiver when suddenly, the sound of music
is heard playing over the speakers of his
ship.
The tune is the national anthem of Nazi Germany.
The captain hails the vessel again, repeating
his attempts at communication.
“Do you..do you understand me?”
At first only static can be heard, then came
a reply..
“You..ship?” the ominous voice could be
heard from the speakers.
The captain hesitated for a moment, members
of the crew looking at each other with apprehension.
The captain replied, confirming themselves
as a ship and then asking if SCP-4217 knew
what is was and where it came from.
What followed was the crew of the SCPS Nemed
receiving a video feed from SCP-4217 featuring
a high volume of images in rapid succession.
Among them were images of German cities, Adolf
Hitler’s telecast of the 1936 Olympics,
an unknown structure in outer space, and in
increasing repetition, images of the planet
Jupiter, particularly the giant storm on Jupiter
known to the public as the Great Red Spot,
or SCP-2399 as foundation members know it.
The transcript of the radio communication
between captain Wagner and SCP-2417 stops
when the video feed begins to focus heavily
on images of Jupiter.
SCP-4217’s responses become more erratic
and agitated as it repeats the words “Storm”,
“Cloud”, and “Red”, the markings on
it’s hulls beginning to light up and the
underwater shadows of it’s tentacles beginning
to create whirlpools of displacement under
the bow of the ship.
A shrill shrieking begins to flood out of
the speakers followed by a piercing high-pitched
beeping sound that overloads the communication
equipment causing sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control panels.
The SCPS Nemed barely escapes as SCP-4217
becomes hostile, using its massive tendril-like
appendages to assail the naval combatants,
firing it’s armamnet in all directions.
After a fierce battle, the Foundation naval
forces were able to neutralize and subdue
SCP-4217.
No further attempts at communication have
been recorded.
To keep the veil of secrecy, Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk and
intentionally re-discovered by oceanographer
Robert Ballard in 1989.
Any recent sightings of the Nazi-era Bismarck
are flagged as misidentifications by SCP staff.
For now, Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of SCP-4217 and protect the public
from its existence.
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-5987 - Sirenhead”
for more anomalous underwater vessels from
SCP Explained!